I must say I meet a lot of people in the
news business and you are truly the
brightest light I have ever met I mean
it you
are you are you are you have just this
you emanate light and hopefulness and
kindness and so thank you I mean this is
really an honor for me to be on
yourday oh my gosh I I I okay thank you
and there's a lot of pain out there in
the world we need people like you yes
well I think part of why I admire you so
much is because you're able to carry
people through that real pain in real
time and how you're able to be the
person that conveys the difficult things
that happen in the world and find the
Hope by the end and the strength and be
the warmth and the safety in moments
that don't feel safe or are devastating
to hear if that's not a human art I
don't know what is Nora so thank you for
being
you um well I think this is going to be
a story close and near and dear to uh
Ross's heart but Nora odonnell please
take it take it away need two of my
favorite things Nora O'Donnell and story
I know so people report that Sher says
her secret to staying young is wearing
jeans and keeping her hair long she's 77
years old she's not ready to give up her
signature long hair it is beautiful if
you had hair like that I mean if I did
I'd keep it that long um and she says
age should not impact how you think
about yourself and she says I'm not
trying to feel young I am who I am I'm
just getting along PR share oh PR and
she looks incredible and you know she
just looks so confident and you know
like jeans and long hair thanks for
sharing share honestly cuz she can turn
back time have you noticed her boyfriend
is like 40 years younger than her too so
it is working get it girl if you can no
wonder she feels young
yeah right I mean you know
I Shar is someone that like I have not
known life or the world without when was
the last time any of us didn't have like
share at the eper center of like fashion
and pop culture and you know I mean like
bring in Shar in her Bob Macky outfits
make the world more colorful what she
would do with sunny and share what she's
done through the 80s and 90s and here
she is it's funny the thing about I'm
not trying to be young it's like age is
not really indicative of who you are I
know older people who are so immature
and young people tot who are so wise and
it's like where you're at and how you
feel like do you either of you feel a
certain age do you feel Timeless how do
you feel well I'm turning 50 God you're
hot oh my
God you are so hot Nora I always tell
you that and I guess you know my mom
says the great thing about getting older
is you care less what people think about
you so that's good
yeah that is good um I've heard but I
also start I do feel like age does I
mean this people say this but it comes
with a lot of wisdom and confidence you
do gain that over time yeah I do feel
like I'm getting that way finally better
better what about you Rosy I I feel like
I'm pretty hip but then the other day my
hip started hurting and I I looked in
the mirror and my hair was gray and now
I have to tinkle in the middle of the
night and I don't know I feel like I
know all the songs on the radio but it's
it's ticking you know getting older and
I always tell you this so we have years
of footage to go back and corroborate
this but you've never looked better like
you love a silver
[Applause]
[Music]
fox